so we brought up consciousness a few
times
there's several things i want to kind of
disentangle there
so one you've recently wrote a paper
titled consciousness religion and gurus
pitfalls of psychedelic medicine
so that's one side of it you've kind of
already mentioned that these terms can
be a little bit misused
or uh are used in a variety of ways
that uh they can they can be confusing
but in a specific way
as much as we can be specific about
these things about the actual heart
problem of consciousness or
understanding
what is consciousness this weird thing
that it feels like
it feels like something to experience
things
have psychedelics giving you some kind
of insight on what
is consciousness you've mentioned that
it feels like psychedelics
allows you to kind of dismantle your
sense of self
like step outside yourself
so that feels like somehow playing with
this mechanism of consciousness
and if it is in fact playing with a
mechanism of consciousness
using just a few chemicals it feels like
we're very
much in the neighborhood of being able
to
maybe understand the actual biological
mechanisms of how consciousness can
emerge from the brain
so yeah there's there's a bunch there i
think my preface is that
i certainly have opinions that are
outside that i can say
here are my best speculations as a as a
as just a person and an armchair
philosopher and it's that philosophy is
certainly not my
my training and my expertise um so i
have thoughts there but
that i recognize are completely in the
realm of speculation
that are like things that i would love
to wrap empirical science around
but that are you know
there's no data and getting to the hard
problem like no conceivable way even
though i'm i'm very open
like i'm hoping that that problem can be
cracked and i do
i as an armchair philosopher i do think
that is a problem i don't think it can
be dismissed as some
people argue it's not even really a
problem it strikes me that that
explaining just the existence of
phenomenal consciousness
is a problem so anyway i i very much
keep that divide in mind when i talk
about these things what we
can really say about what we've learned
through science including by
psychedelics versus like
what i can speculate on in in terms of
you know
the nature of reality and consciousness
but
in terms of by and large
skeptically i have to say psychedelics
have not really taught us
anything about the nature of
consciousness i'm hopeful that they will
they
they have been used around certain i
don't even know if features is the right
term
but things that are called consciousness
so consciousness can refer to not
only just phenomenal consciousness which
is like you know
the the source of the hard problem and
what it is to be like nagel's
um description but um
the sense of self or so which can be
sort of like the the experiential
self momentum or it can be like the
narrative self the string
together of story so those are things
that i think
can be and a little bit's been done
with with psychedelics regarding that
but i i think there's far more potential
like
but so like one story that unfolded is
that
psychedelics acutely having effects on
the default mode network a certain a
pattern of activation amongst a subset
of brain areas that is
associated with self-referential
processing seems to be more active more
communication
between these um uh areas like uh the
posterior cingulate cortex and the
medial prefrontal cortex for example
being parts of this that are
and others that are um tied with sort of
thinking about yourself remembering
yourself in the past projecting yourself
into the future
and so that it's an interesting story
emerged
when it was found that when psilocybin
is on board you know in the person
system that there's a
there's less communication amongst these
these areas so
with resting state fmri imaging that
there's
there's less synchronization or
presumably communication between these
areas and so
i think it was it has been overstated
and ah we see this is like this is the
dissolving of the ego
this is it the story made a whole lot of
sense but
there's several i think that story is
really being challenged like one we see
increasing number of drugs that are that
that decouple that network including
ones like that
aren't psychedelic so this may just be a
property
frankly of being like you know screwed
up you know like
you know being out of your head being
like like you know anytime you mess with
a perception system maybe
it screws up some some uh just our
ability to just function in the
holistically like we do in order yeah
for the brain to perceive stuff to be
able to map it to memory to connect
things together their their whole recur
mechanism
that that could just be messed with
right and it couldn't i'm speculating it
could be tied to more if you had to
download in the language everyday
language like
not feeling like yourself like so
whether that be like really drunk or
really hopped up on amphetamine
or you know on like we found it like
decoupling of the default mode network
on salvan ornay which is a smokable
psychedelic which is a non-classic
psychedelic but another one where
like dmt where people are often talking
to entities and that type of thing that
was a really fun study to run but
nonetheless
most people say it's not a classic
psychedelic and doesn't
have some some of those phenomenal
features that people report from classic
psychedelics
and not sort of the clear sort of ego
loss type not at least not in the way
that people report it with classic
psychedelics so you get it with all
these different drugs and so
and then you also see just broad broad
changes in network activity with other
networks
and so i think that story took off a
little too soon although
so i think in in the story that the dmn
the default mode network
relating to the self and i know some
neuroscientists it drives them crazy if
you say that
it's the ego and that's just like
but self-referential processing if you
go that far
like that was already known before
psychedelic psychedelics didn't
really contribute to that the idea that
this
type of brain network activity was
related to a sense of self
but it is absolutely striking that
psychedelics that people report with
pretty high reliability these unity
experiences that
where people subjectively like like they
report losing or
again like the boundaries of the however
you want to say it like
like these these unity experiences i
think we can do a lot with that in terms
of figuring out the nature
of the sense of self
you